everyone here has huge boobs i'm 32
thanks to lenny
32 triple d
show the girls off to everybody
okay i missed something i could have
something but it was a
dream have never seen adriana's triple d
or whatever d in my life i was like wow
great great great job lenny yeah i feel
like i'm taking the questions thank you
lenny is still known as the boob god i'm
removing this
to tighten the breast and lifters
yeah they feel hard they do not feel
hard like super fake lisa you've seen
adriana's boobs before i've seen them
how is it possible yeah wait is this
your first time seeing your boots no
comments
grabbing my butt her butt's juicy and
soft now i just need to get lars a
secret i need to get her booty and then
get me on oh
[Music]
yes
why not a girl
newly single freshly single i have to be
independent i have to provide for myself
so larson might have a little
competition
initially i was like
it has like a very
risque sexual connotation to it but
that's instagram too instagram is pg-13
only fans
is
because you know i was the first one to
be like
that's super [ __ ]
but i think he will be pleasantly
surprised what is everything
extensiveness of the platform
i think nicole is quite sneaky
and i don't trust her
because i've heard that she
has said not very nice things about some
of the girls and then when she's in
front of them she's like they're besties
and that
is never a good sign yeah it's not just
girls showing boobs and whatever my
things
[Music]
a month to show your workout videos you
wouldn't pay five dollars a month to
show
are you gonna pay with five dollars
don't subscribe to peloton a month
[Music]
i think we live in a world that's way
too judgmental
if larsa wants to have and only fans she
wants to make ten thousand dollars a day
let her
maybe she can teach me
what would you do with an extra 10 000 a
day
with an extra 10 000 a day
the new lisa would invest that
the old lisa would go to hermes and blow
it all i think that the optics of only
fans by initial like reactions like oh
no i don't do that why do people
associate only friends with like showing
skin and body they get sellers are the
ones who are showing skin absolutely
skin cells
who cares the truth is that we're super
like old-school old-fashioned
we're like we have like this thing like
this doctrinal thing that like our
parents i guess
they're worried about my only fans
meanwhile they're on their third or
fourth marriages who were these people
to judge me
i'm with you
[Music]
you